nous sommes des Africains c'est l'Afrique alors
développons ce pays pour l'Afrique par l'
Afrique
[Musique]
une raison pour laquelle ces jeunes
risquent leur vie pour aller sur le petit
bateau pour traverser la Méditerranée c'est
parce qu'ils ne voient aucun espoir dans leur
vous savez qu'il n'y a pas d'
institutions d'enseignement supérieur il
n'y a pas d'économie stable la
situation politique est pleine d'
incertitudes donc ce que nous devons faire c'est
veiller à ce que les jeunes de leur propre
pays aient accès à l'éducation aient
accès à  l'information ont accès pour
s'améliorer et aussi rendre l'
agriculture attractive parce que beaucoup de
jeunes si vous leur demandez à quoi
ressemble le succès ils vous diront que je
porte un costume
je ne peux pas mallette et je vais dans un
air-  constructeur conditionné mais si vous
leur dites qu'en fait le monsieur qui
vend du boeuf en costume de travail avec
des bottes de pluie gagne beaucoup plus d'argent
que le gars qui est assis derrière l'
ordinateur, ils ne croient pas  vous jusqu'à ce que
vous leur montriez jusqu'à ce que vous le rendiez sexy,
nous voulons donc nous assurer de ramener le
sexy dans l'agriculture, mais plus
important encore, nous voulons que le monde développé
France Amérique Grande-Bretagne s'associe
à nous, mais quand ils s'associent à nous,
ils doivent venir  et écouter et
comprendre ce que nous
voulons réellement et nous aider en ce sens qu'ils
ne devraient pas venir avec des idées
préconçues sur la façon dont les choses devraient évoluer, ils devraient
venir s'engager avec les Africains afin que nous puissions
travailler ensemble dans un véritable partenariat pour
développer notre pays et  de cette façon, nous pouvons
vraiment nous assurer que de moins en moins de
gens risquent leur vie pour
venir vous chercher des opportunités,
nous sommes allés en Amérique pour la première fois
et bien sûr nous sommes allés à Disney World
et bien sûr vous êtes à Disney World  vous
voulez monter sur les montagnes russes,
nous allons descendre la ligne et alors que nous arrivons
au début de la ligne, nous avons un
monsieur qui nous aide à monter sur les montagnes
russes et alors salut comment allez-vous
de non  Je viens d'Afrique du Sud Wow Afrique du
Sud dites-moi quelle est la taille des lions
et j'étais comme si je regardais mon cousin vous
savez que nous sommes très confus et j'ai dit
désolé monsieur je ne travaille pas au zoo je
n'en ai aucune idée  à quel point les lions deviennent gros et j'ai donc
commencé à réaliser que les gens en dehors
du continent africain ont
une connaissance très limitée de l'Afrique et que le
peu d'informations dont ils disposent sont
assez négatives, ce qui est perpétué par
les médias grand public
, nous devons donc faire quelque chose pour mettre en valeur
les aspects positifs de  Afrique
[Musique]
actuellement en Afrique du Sud, dans de nombreuses régions d'
Afrique, le chômage des jeunes est de 60 à 70%
à 80% dans certaines régions d'Afrique et
il est donc important que ces jeunes
aient les compétences et la
formation nécessaires pour pouvoir entrer
l'économie formelle afin qu'ils puissent
briser le cycle de la pauvreté qui existe
donc ce que nous voulons, c'est autonomiser les
jeunes afin qu'ils puissent
s'autonomiser pour être à l'avant-garde du développement de l'
Afrique, nous ne voulons pas de
sociétés multinationales  rations d'être
ceux qui bénéficient du développement
qui se déroule en Afrique, nous voulons que
les jeunes soient les principaux
bénéficiaires et ceux qui conduisent le
développement ainsi une des choses
que mon terrain pour ceux que vous faites en
fait quand il le voulait  à sa
sortie de prison, il voulait abaisser l'âge
du droit de vote à 16 ans, mais il n'a pas
réussi en ce qu'il croit que les
jeunes savent ce qu'ils veulent Nelson
Mandela croyait que les jeunes
devraient être les leaders et devraient avoir une
voix c'est  probablement la voix la plus importante
de la société